well I think I feel like everyone should
know on the face shown right now we just
heard of pre-cum as pre-christmas in an
inn that yeah and that is just he has
baby want a little bit of my
pre-christmas who is that pre-christmas
oh oh wait here comes the eggnog
oh my [ __ ] is full of pre-christmas
right now bro grab that computer
let's get multimedia on these [ __ ]
computer dude let's watch some porn porn
together dude
grab that [ __ ] let's get multimedia on
these [ __ ] on these [ __ ] asses are
we rolling on that one um I don't know
you want me check yeah intertwine
intertwine you guys that's some [ __ ]
just bring me the ninja fellas make some
noise if you got if you right if you
rolling around with pre-christmas right
now fellas make some noise if you got a
little pre-christmas yeah I'm saying on
your way to work ladies let us know
ladies Carlene now let us know how you
feel about pre-christmas stained on your
underwear
yeah plug it in turn on that mic yeah a
little bit of pre actually it'll find
it's fine it'll it'll sink it yeah it's
fine it's fine
call now and tell us about your pre
Christmas experience and what how you
feel about pre-christmas hold on we got
a caller calling in right now Boop Jenny
you're on the line how do you feel about
pre Christmas um I [ __ ] hate pre
Christmas I think it's disgusting I
don't think we should do it anymore
Wow strong opinions there let's cut over
to
Dillon in Indiana Dillon Indiana how do
you feel about pre-christmas um I'm you
know what I've heard that with
pre-christmas also contains a lot of
stockings semen sperm sperm sperm that's
what gets girls pregnant right super not
semen what's the difference
same thing yes semen all right well
let's let's just go ahead and ruin the
search history here sperm versus semen
sperm we're sitting and that's um it's
actually a new movie coming out chance
Channing Tatum vs Jonah Hill 25 Jump
Street sperm versus semen you just
[ __ ] sperm everywhere sperm versus
semen sperm 15 crazy things you should
know about sperm you think how crazy do
you think these facts are I love this
this is like we're just hanging out just
using the computer like old times
remember yeah like invite your boys over
to use the computer yeah hell yeah well
come over this just Google [ __ ] yeah
just be on the internet legit you should
just go on the internet with my boys
yeah there's just like not even [ __ ]
porn nothing online being online doin
[ __ ] and just looking at this thing it
actually is kind of sick uh-huh that's
[ __ ] you know your dad looks like
Neil Lance Armstrong I'm looking at a
picture of him right now just picture my
dad no Lance Armstrong reminds me of
your dad is a picture of Lance Armstrong
right in front of me right now why are
you looking at a picture of hawaiians
Armstrong because I was looking at the
15 crazy things for sperm and then I
clicked over to see a fact and it said
one testicle is enough it was showing
Lance Armstrong such a [ __ ] great
that's what they should put for like
ball like ball cancer removal mm-hmm
this is a picture of Lance and one ball
is enough one balls enough open up that
[ __ ] tik-tok that I sent to the team
G talking points ladies and gentlemen
this is how would you describe this guy
me neither
I really know yeah he's a he's a special
one
he's a special one this is our boy right
here are we gonna get copyrighted for
playing as whatever um we shouldn't I've
got some people make compilations all
the time yeah I know and they get
[ __ ] claimed whatever play it it's
too good night it's so funny let me show
ya let's let's reset let's reset but I
gotta get off um all right guys you
ready for this let's go this is just
mm-hmm I've got some [ __ ] I gotta get
off my chest and I don't use Twitter so
you're dealing with it here if you did
not start smoking weed out of a [ __ ]
apple or a can or a water bottle or some
[ __ ] you made in your shop class you're
not a [ __ ] stoner your carts don't
make you a STONER so get the [ __ ] off I
snapchat with your stickers I don't get
the sticker your stickers I think he
means like goodbye like the stickers on
the [ __ ] screen like the doors yeah
wait what our carts cartridges yeah yeah
like vape yeah yeah babe cars just man
you're not a [ __ ] stoner goodbye
goodbye Hey look just drop the [ __ ]
fattest bomb you [ __ ] idiot you're
not a [ __ ] stoner goodbye the
goodbyes the VIP goodbye you're not a
[ __ ] stoner who is that [ __ ]
heated about kids showing off vape pens
on snapchat Jonah and Gucci man you
pissed like you feel that passionately
about [ __ ] you being a stoner means
that much to you I mean are we getting
got right now is this a bit did you Pete
the rest of this man's profile Oh see
dude can't just take it at face value
okay oh look I just found this [ __ ]
hamster in the street outside and I mean
I seem kind of cute so I got him a cage
and I throw him in my backyard but will
someone tell me why my [ __ ] guinea
pig is just out here looking like such a
prick I keep feeding him watermelon and
he's not eating it I mean like look at
this me and
here you yeah I mean you just wouldn't
really understand because you're not a
[ __ ] stoner so get off [ __ ] snap
chat with your stickers guy later bye
the worst part about that is that like
went viral yeah like people were like I
agree with this dude yeah dude speaking
the truth man dude oh man you said it
beautifully said we're all thinking bro
it's like oh my god I mean yeah [ __ ]
Jesus you ready for this I'm a goth boy
says I mean yeah cart smokers ain't
really stoners but I started smoking out
of a pipe yay for gatekeeping I guess
l'm al the gatekeeping on stoning is
being a STONER is so good they should
remake Blade Runner 2049 but instead of
like robots and like sub subhuman class
citizens they should just be stoners and
cart smokers shut the [ __ ] up cart
smoker get back in line bro is that a
term cart smoker only use term I don't
know let's google it ya mean the boys
smoking carts now card smoker 108 inches
so it's like a literal type of smoker 84
inch cart smoker huh doesn't seem like
it's lying dude let me go you're not a
[ __ ] stoner you're not a [ __ ]
stoner listen bro if you never what some
stupid ass [ __ ] that you used to do to
smoke weed but you ever you ever bacon
you ever baked it on like a cracker with
peanut butter you ever do that No
so it's like is the easiest no no it's
like the easiest way to make [ __ ]
edibles okay if you don't have like [ __ ]
to make brownies or whatever you take
the crook saltine yeah and you spread
peanut butter peanut butter on it yeah
then you just sprinkle weed on top and
you bake them and like the oil from the
peanut butter or so it makes in the THC
bakes inside of it I made those a couple
times I remember if you've never done
that you're not a [ __ ] stoner you
never [ __ ] say oh dude yeah that
that's what everyone should be talking
about although
horrible stupid ways to get high yeah
this fool is upset because people don't
have to do dumbass [ __ ] to get high
anymore yeah this is mad that's what it
is yeah it's kind of like some boomer
[ __ ] a little bit a little bit yeah
millennial boomer not a millennial
boomer [ __ ] that's a thing dude
millennial boomer is there needs to be a
term for that
yeah I'm a Boomer yeah that's me talking
about the peloton right yeah yeah boom
Eleni illumine millennial boomer are
like are like Facebook people it's all
they are like I feel like that's the
best way to describe them yeah sort of
like dick I know it's kind of tik-tok
people now yeah they're bleeding out I'm
just saying like that that's what I feel
like that's where they spawn from yeah
is there like Facebook people yeah you
know or like or like grown men tweeting
[ __ ] and then like adding hashtags
mm-hmm
like you ever seen a grown man tweet
something like three hashtag is there
any on that is it like fyp for you page
as other ones had that in it yeah it's
like dude you're not a [ __ ] stoner go
by go by okay listen if you never
hashtag your post a bunch of [ __ ]
times
you've never been an instagramer you're
not a [ __ ] kick talker goodbye bye
[Laughter]
millennial boomer [ __ ] to the fullest
yeah I want to [ __ ] I how how many
people I wonder
probably at no.1 or at probably a ton
someone just needs to get on there and
just like duet with this fool and be
like like just the most obscure way to
smoke weed if you'd never like like he's
like a 80 year old man it was like if
you've never smoked shake weed
it has literal twigs in it and you had
to pull out the [ __ ] twigs and dust
it with miracle-gro for like a week you
are not a [ __ ] stoner good bye bye
if you've never laced your weed with
pre-christmas
because your tongue was too dry from all
the weed you were smoking you got
cottonmouth so you can't actually roll a
joint and you need your pre-christmas to
seal the joint then you're not a [ __ ]
stoner goodbye bye if you've never
smoked weed at literal Woodstock you're
not a STONER goodbye smoking it evidence
funny of you like like bloggers and [ __ ]
like like it like Instagram girls like
if you've never eaten a rustic canyon on
Wilshire Boulevard you are not a foodie
good bye good bye
if you've never driven a Honda Civic
with the third gear pop out and your
fifth gear kind of shredding because you
[ __ ] with the final drive in your boys
garage and now you [ __ ] up the whole
transmission and you have to wait six
months to buy a whole new transmission
you're not a [ __ ] Rai sir goodbye if
you've never waited in line at a Sephora
for that new drop you are not a beauty
guru goodbye bye bye if you've never cut
the springs on your Honda Civic to make
it lower so you can look fly as [ __ ] in
high school you're not a real honda head
goodbye oh my god that's [ __ ] awesome
if you've never eaten [ __ ] with your
ass in the air you don't really eat
[ __ ] goodbye with your ass in the air
ya like it when you're both on the bed
oh yeah yeah yeah you got a real
yeah yeah yeah pop this you gotta pop
your cake yeah now I never I always make
sure if if I start to even get into that
position I'm like no not like I'll do it
all day I'll do a handstand I handle
duis and a [ __ ]
do a handstand in that [ __ ] yeah it's
not very ergonomic dude yeah
16:07 talk about ergonomics dude [ __ ]
give it a [ __ ] you gotta [ __ ] if you
care about ergonomics while you're
losing you're a virgin July
[Laughter]
[Music]